Speaker 4: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Greg Tucker Kellogg, who's a biology
professor at the National University of Singapore.
He also has a YouTube channel addressing scientific
misinformation on social media, of which there
is a lot right now. A great, really great
to have you on. Greg, I appreciate it.
Speaker 5: Well, thanks, thanks for having
me.
Speaker 4: So I want to eventually work towards
ivermectin, which you've been talking about
quite a bit on your channel, but maybe first
we could talk a little bit about, you know,
since the early days in the pandemic there,
there have been these kind of clusters of
treatment ideas that are proposed. And I want
to be careful how I how I describe them, because
just because something is proposed as a treatment
doesn't mean it is a treatment for COVID.
And early on it was hydroxychloroquine, azithromycin,
maybe vitamin D, although vitamin D was, I
think, proposed more prophylactically than
some of these other things, and eventually
ivermectin was added to the list. Generally
speaking, my idea has been that most of the
proposed so-called treatments are cheap, ubiquitous
things which are mostly available in much
of the world. And that's so in some sense,
it makes sense that we would at least ask,
might these things be used to be useful? Is
that a fair assessment of how some of these
things start?
Speaker 5: Absolutely. So there's a whole
area of drug discovery and drug development
that's referred to as drug repurposing. And
so the idea is to take drugs that are available
for other purposes and to see if they can
be basically well repurposed and found utility
in something like an emergency like COVID.
And so there were lots of tests around the
world and actually large screening programs.
There was a fairly large screening program
at the NIH, for example, that was screening
through approved drugs to see whether they
would have activity in various viral assays
and those screening programs. Eventually,
you know, they generated some interest and
there were some follow ups. But yeah, there's
there's a lot of interest in seeing whether
some of those things can be can be used. And
of course, steroid treatments are now a mainstay
of treatment for for COVID 19. So some of
that has been really, really useful.
Speaker 4: When this is done are really expensive
drug sometimes tested. And what I mean by
that is I haven't heard of expensive cancer
drugs being tested to see. Might that work
for COVID, for example? I mean, is it typically
the cheap stuff?
Speaker 5: Well, it's typically everything
that's approved because one of the one of
the things one would like to be able to do
with a drug in particular is to be able to
skip the the safety trials. So if you know,
if you already know that it's safe, then that's
fine. But actually, in the case of cancer,
you know, a lot of traditional cancer drugs
are a chemotherapeutic are effectively poisonous.
And so it's not so much the price. But you
know, there are other reasons not to give
them to something to say a COVID patient.
Speaker 4: So in terms of the appropriate
way to determine whether a drug works to treat
a disease like COVID, in the last two years,
we've seen every iteration from a French doctor
gave hydroxychloroquine to 38 people, and
here is sort of like his sense of how they
did all the way to some actual randomized
controlled trials for ivermectin, comparing
it to the standard of care versus a placebo,
et cetera. So talk a little bit about sort
of like the ideal formulation of the way we
would test something for COVID.
Speaker 5: Sure. Well, I'll speak to like
the drug discovery and clinical trial aspects
of it. So when one does you know, drug discovery,
when one does clinical trials you, you like
to try to treat or to test new drugs or drugs
for a new purpose in a way that is relevant.
So sometimes it might be preclinical studies,
screening for large numbers. And then as you
get to more expensive studies like clinical
trials, you move to smaller groups. So there's
some of the most important trials in this
have been with the Go platform trials where
they're looking at a large number of different
agents. So the Together trial, for example,
is such a platform trial and they look at
a number of agents. There's been some really
good things that have come out with this,
but it's not just, you know, it's not just
everything in the kitchen saying you have
to make choices judiciously with the evidence
that you have and move forward with the things
that have the most promise.
Speaker 4: In general, when we have now, when
we're two years into this pandemic, there
is somewhat of an accepted standard of care
for how moderate to severe COVID is treated
in hospital settings. So if we want to introduce
the idea of measuring the effect of something
like ivermectin, would we always be testing
it against the standard of care rather than
against nothing because few people would just
get nothing? Is that an important aspect of
this?
Speaker 5: Yeah, so in. Right. So in clinical
trials, there's there's a principle of equipoise
where you don't want to give an inferior treatment.
You know, ethically, you want to know that
you're giving at least the standard of care.
Obviously, if there is no standard of care,
then that's another situation. But if you
have a standard of care, you want to be giving
it. Also, of course, has over the last year
as a lot of people have gotten vaccinated
and as people have had prior infection. So
there's some protection from immunity, and
that also complicates trials. There's lots
of things that complicate trials over time,
but certainly you want to give. You don't
want to deny the standard of care to somebody
in a clinical trial
Speaker 4: and again, in an ideal formulation
with something like ivermectin. Would you
really want three groups, one group that is
just the standard of care group and everybody
knows they're not receiving ivermectin? And
then you would have a placebo group and an
ivermectin group, and they don't know whether
they are receiving the ivermectin. Is that?
Would that be the ideal setup?
Speaker 5: So in the in the first case that
you're talking about where you know, people
now, you know, so it's generally two groups,
it's two arms in one particular setting, even
of a platform trial. So in a platform trial,
they might be looking at multiple different
settings. But you want to be able to compare
the people who are getting the standard of
care and the people who are getting the standard
of care and then maybe some new agent fare.
Speaker 4: A few weeks ago, you did a great
interview with Yakub Effah Manko about a study
or conference abstract, as maybe it's better
referred to on ivermectin. I did a much less
detailed segment on that. And this was one
that really caught fire everybody from Jordan
Peterson to Dr. John Campbell, who I don't
say this pejoratively. He's not a medical
doctor. I just I feel driven to say that because
there's some confusion about about his credentials.
Initially said, Wow, 70 percent reduction
in mortality for people given ivermectin.
You extensively broke that down, including
with one of the authors of the conference,
Abstract, who said this was retrospective
observational data we don't know about dosing.
The groups weren't separated by vaccine status.
There's all these other problems with this.
Why do you think that caught such fire on
social media because the result was just notable
and it made a great headline?
Speaker 5: Yeah. So I'm I mean, I'm learning
a lot about how this misinformation train
works and ivermectin seems to be the gift
that keeps on grifting. And so what happens
is, in this case, it was just a conference
abstract that it had this kind of startling
result or a result that could be spun in a
way that was startling and seemed dramatic.
And so that little thing gets amplified into
something much larger. And then the results
that are presented in the in the conference
abstract were then taken way out of context
and misrepresented in other ways and all the
limitations of the conference abstract, which
led to it not being published. They weren't
talked about, and so it just seemed like it
was something much, much larger, much more
definitive than it was. And that is what keeps
happening over and over again.
Speaker 4: I have no, you know, I think one
of the sad things about this is it's very
easy to say this stuff has become politicized
and in a certain sense, it has. But I'm not
aware of people who don't want ivermectin
or hydroxychloroquine or the Z packs to work.
I mean, I would love it if we had evidence
that something really cheap and widely available
was effective. So I feel like it's it's not
uniformly or symmetrically politicized. I
just want to be able to say we have or we
don't have evidence that this works. But it
really does seem particularly here in the
United States, that there are people who attach
to any one of these ideas and they almost
stop caring about what the data show.
Speaker 5: Yeah, so it's it's frustrating,
so I'm not a medical doctor, either, I'm a
scientist, I'm a I'm a biologist, a biophysicist
by training. Yes, and the it's it's frustrating
because what's happening in this case is that
people are latching onto these and then they're
they're latching on to things that have not
been shown to be effective. Instead of moving
forward with things that are effective, they
have been shown to be effective. And that's
the real tragedy of this because they keep
latching on to it. And I think it's actually
not just I wouldn't say it's a failure of
science. So in the case of f a Mako, it was
not a failure of science science work. They
decided not to publish the paper, but it was
a terrible failure of science communication.
And that's what keeps happening so that the
the misuse tends to exploit the ignorance
of people about how science communication
works and kind of widens that gap so people
don't know what a conference abstract is.
And then they take that lack of knowledge,
the public lack of knowledge and just, you
know. Build on it.
Speaker 4: In thinking back now to that earlier
list that I mentioned of ideas that there
were early in the pandemic, and if you're
not prepared to go into this, that that's
fine, I'm kind of springing this on you. It
seems that the vitamin D piece has had some
favorable results where compared to a placebo.
Generally speaking, the correct level of vitamin
D has a generally protective effect. It's
not a treatment for COVID, but it seems as
though what we suspected about vitamin D that
if you're if your level is low, you're more
susceptible to illness. That seems to have
been confirmed, right? I mean, that seems
one of the early things we learned.
Speaker 5: So I think there was a lot of that.
There was a lot of conflicting data on this
as well. There were encouraging signs, but.
There was just a large study published, I
think, within the last week, and I have the
study on my to read list, but I haven't read
it and it doesn't show any benefit. Oh, it
does vitamin D, you know? Yeah. So it's a
negative result for vitamin D
Speaker 4: and is that for supplementation
generally or just looking at if you're deficient
versus you're not, you might be better or
worse off.
Speaker 5: So this is where we're get I wish
I had read the study right, right? I've read
that study, so I don't want to misspeak on
that fair.
Speaker 4: But but that seems to be a fundamental
question. I guess that should be answered.
Speaker 5: Yes, so in the case of vitamin
D, I think the argument had been that perhaps
a deficiency would have been something to
address, but then that doesn't mean anything
about supplementation. Right. So if you're
if you're not deficient, then supplementation
wouldn't necessarily be assumed to have any
have any benefit. And in this case, I honestly,
I haven't read the study results. So very
I don't want to misrepresent it.
Speaker 4: You teach in Singapore. I'm curious
if you can kind of give us some insights as
to whether the entire media and social media
landscape around these discussions is different
there than in the United States, which which
has been completely out of control and rife
with misinformation and disinformation. What's
the sort of feel there of these discussions
Speaker 5: in social media or the news media,
Speaker 4: either that you feel comfortable
commenting on?
Speaker 5: Sure. Well, I mean, the news media
is pretty tame here. And so that said, there's
not much in in the news media, in the social
media, there's been some there's actually
been a pro ivermectin group. And as often
happens, their fellow travelers in this tend
to be anti-vaccine. And so there's they've
been pro ivermectin, anti-vax anti mandate
and and some of some of them have gotten into
legal trouble. And that's they've used social
media, Telegram groups, Facebook groups and
so on to to basically work, to do their work
and spread their message. And in fact, in
some sense, that's how I got into this because
somebody had been influenced by these groups
and asked me for help, ask me to help her
understand these things. And kind of ultimately,
she ended up getting a vaccine, but it took
a while.
Speaker 4: Mm hmm. Well, the YouTube channel
is excellent. You really break these things
down in a way that is both detailed but also
accessible, which I think it's so important
right now when we talk about science communication.
I want to suggest to everybody in my audience.
Check out Greg Tucker Kellogg's YouTube channel.
Greg is a biology professor at the National
University of Singapore. Really appreciate
your time today.
Speaker 5: Well, thanks very much, David.
Really nice talking to you.